what do we know if anything well I mean
right now the rumor says that Apple may
be developing an electric car to compete
with the likes of Tesla but as you know
Apple has been in the business on
creating something that's new that's out
of the box electric cars on a really a
new device but something that may
integrate the automobile to the rest of
the world run to the apple ecosystem if
you will yes just like iTunes did with
music just like you know Apple pay is to
pay services no maybe another some sort
of device that integrates the automobile
into the rest of the world you know and
connects it to eco system may be in the
play okay the question got already is
why would you move into something which
is totally different well it's not it's
not like as you know Apple has been very
good at developing smart devices they
probably are hiring all these you know
industry expert automotive industry
experts just to understand how the
automobile works how to interact with
its surrounding how it you know how it
how people interacts with an automobile
so you know apples trying to understand
how that entire ecosystem works and
probably developing a smart device that
integrates itself into the into the
automobile